I use organic bloom all natural
fertilizer it's
[Music]
advertised here as an ad blocker so
block ads browse safer browse faster
back in 2012 Adblock cost Google
887 million dollars by 2015 this number
Rose to 6.6 billion and by 2020 Adblock
was causing Publishers to lose 35
billion dollars worth of AD Revenue
every single year but that doesn't seem
like Google cares all that much in fact
the most popular ad block is offered
through the Chrome web store itself with
hundreds of thousands of reviews and a
total of 350 million downloads you would
think that any reasonable ad business
would have taken this down by now or at
least taken steps to make Adblock
ineffective I mean Adblock surely has no
chance against Google's tens of
thousands of Engineers right well the
answer is yes and a perfect example of
this is the YouTube app due to the
design of mobile apps no Adblock can
block ads on the YouTube app itself but
there is a way around this on mobile
devices instead of using the YouTube app
you can use a mobile browser along with
Adblock so while Google has added
roadblocks along the way they haven't
gone as far as completely taking down
Adblock even though they could
theoretically do it quite easily in fact
they have not only not taken steps to
eliminate Adblock but Google has
actually been supporting Adblock they've
been paying Adblock tens of millions
every year to whitelist ads and this is
how Adblock makes much of the revenue to
remain operational hearing this you
would probably think that Google has
come to accept that Adblock is an
unavoidable loss in Revenue similar to
piracy within the media industry but
what if I told you that Adblock is
actually beneficial for Google it
actually increases their click-through
rates conversion rates and even ad rates
it also allows them to maintain their
domineering Monopoly within the browser
space and their search space and if you
don't believe me just listen to this
back in 20 17 Google was trying to build
their own ad block that would be built
into Chrome so here's why Google has not
only not taken down Adblock but why they
pay ad block tens of millions and
support the overall effort
foreign
first of all Google isn't stupid they're
not gonna support Adblock if they think
that it's a net loss for the company the
reality is that allowing Adblock is more
beneficial for Google than blocking it
and one of the main reasons for this is
that it allows them to protect their
Monopoly here's the thing Chrome is by
far the most popular browser in the
world with over 60 market share across
all devices but if you look closer
you'll see that chroma is the only
browser that's backed by an ad business
Safari is backed by Apple who is mainly
a hardware and services business they do
have plans around entering the ad space
but that has yet to happen in a
substantial manner as per Edge well and
it's just backed by Microsoft who
basically doesn't even need a
consumer-based revenue anymore as
they've transitioned to becoming an
Enterprise business and finally as for
the last notable player we have a
Firefox who is a non-profit who's
actually staying afloat thanks to
donations from Google if you're
wondering why in the world do Google
pays Firefox be sure to check out our
video on that but getting back to
browsers Chrome is the only browser
that's dependent on an ad based Revenue
Google is an ad business and they make
most of their money on ads that's not
surprising just think about it what
happens if Google stopped allowing
Adblock on Chrome well Adblock suddenly
becomes a selling feature for everyone
else of course they're not gonna just
publicly tell you that you should switch
to Safari because it has ad block that
would probably be bad PR they might make
a public deal with Adblock or feature
the Adblock app on the app store or pay
journalists to make a comparison between
the browsers all of this would result in
much of the 315 million users who
currently have Adblock to consider or
even switch to one of these other
browsers but by making Adblock easily
accessible on Chrome Google is able to
protect this massive segment of the
market Adblock isn't just effective at
defending off large players either it's
also effective at fending off new up and
becoming players as well all of the
browsers that we just discussed were
created by established companies as an
afterthought and that's why they don't
need ads but if you want to have a
chance at taking on Chrome you too would
have to allow ad block and while that's
sustainable for Google with their nearly
300 billion dollars worth of Revenue
it's unlikely that it would be
sustainable for you so from Google's
perspective allowing Adblock May mean
sacrificing some Revenue but the
alternative is sacrificing market share
which is a lot more valuable
foreign
market share Adblock actually allows
Google to have far better ad performance
here's the thing what type of person is
gonna go out of their way to get the
Adblock extension or use Safari to watch
YouTube instead of the YouTube app well
the answer is someone who really doesn't
want to see ads ironically this is
almost half of the internet as 42.7
percent of the world uses some form of
Adblock now Google could force ads on
these people but given their extreme
distaste for ads they would be far less
likely to convert which is not exactly a
great thing for Google due to how their
ad business is structured in more
traditional media like TV and movies
advertisers pay networks and Studios
based on visibility this is why it costs
7 million dollars to air a 30 second
commercial on their Super Bowl they get
paid the same amount whether the ad gets
a one percent conversion rate or a 50
conversion rate in other words the
broadcaster doesn't promise any sort of
perform performance and likewise their
compensation isn't based on performance
Google also doesn't promise advertisers
at any sort of performance but there's a
catch Google only gets paid if the ad
performs because they use a model called
it pay-per-click in this model
advertisers will bid on how much money
they're willing to pay per click and the
person with the highest bid it will be
displayed first on search results or
YouTube or whatever so theoretically I
could bid an insane amount like one
thousand dollars per click and Google
could go ahead and push that to a
billion people but if not a single
person clicks I wouldn't have to pay
Google a single dime conversely someone
could bid a much more modest one dollar
per click and the ad could be pushed to
just 1 million people but if this
campaign had a 10 click-through rate
this Advertiser would have to pay Google
a hundred thousand dollars Google isn't
paid on visibility their paid on results
and so even though Google doesn't to
promise any sort of result it's in their
best interest that advertisers perform
well and one of the easiest ways to do
this is to cut out the people who don't
want to see ads these people would
simply be inflating impression counts
deflating click-through rates and
putting off advertisers I think the Lost
Revenue estimates are actually super
inaccurate I'm not exactly sure how
numbers like this are calculated but
they're probably using some sort of
basic forecasting model if x number of
viewers lead to this much ad Revenue why
number of viewers should lead to this
much ad Revenue but for this to be
accurate the ads would have to perform
as well with a wide number of viewers as
it did with X number of viewers which as
we discussed is unlikely if the extra
viewers were 10 times less likely to
click well then the loss in Revenue
wouldn't be 35 billion it would actually
be three and a half billion by focusing
on likely act targets Google may have
been able to increase ad bits to a point
at widget offsets this cost so Adblock
may not just be a market share move for
Google it could straight up be a
profitable move
thank you
so far we've been discussing how Google
has been quite accommodating of Adblock
but this is not 100 of the story you see
Google is only accommodating when we're
talking about Revenue that's auxiliary
or a bonus they're not actually all that
tolerant when it comes to their Core
Business take search ads for example
Google didn't waste a second when it
came to striking a deal with Adblock to
whitelist Google search ads the same
thing can be said about any add-on any
google-based platform Adblock isn't
stopping inbuilt ads on Google Maps or
Gmail or Google flights or Google books
or Google shopping or even mobile
YouTube even if you found some ad block
that accomplishes this well and still
not stopping Google from continuing to
collect data on you and trying to serve
ads through other venues so the bottom
line is that Google isn't actually
seating in any of their core businesses
the part of the business that they're
seating on it is the ability to put ads
on third-party websites if we zoom out
we'll see that sitting here isn't even a
loss for Google it's actually a gain
because of Google's most valuable asset
isn't advertising their number one goal
is to consume as much of your attention
as possible and prevent you from going
on to tick tock or Instagram or Twitter
if you go search for an article and all
of the ads on the article are blocked
that's not a big deal as long as you're
still researching it you're gonna go
back to Google make more searches see
more sponsored results and visit more
websites which may have whitelisted ads
what would be a true loss for Google is
if you visit a website or bombarded by
10 ads and decide to go scroll through
Tick Tock Instead This is the main
reason that Chrome itself has an inbuilt
ad blocker that's automatically enabled
you may not have known this but Google
themselves blocks all ads on websites
that they deem to have poor ad
experiences this includes sites with too
many ads ads with flashing graphics and
auto playing audio and AdWords in many
cases these ads may be getting displayed
through Google ads so Google is
technically cutting off their own
Revenue in the short term but they're
betting that this will lead to a greater
user experience and stronger retention
which will theoretically be more
profitable over the long term
foreign
Google has taken an extremely
sophisticated approach when it comes to
Adblock given that they're an ad
business it would have been easy for
them to complain it through a tantrum
and try to eliminate all remnants of
Adblock but instead it they've looked to
structure ad block in a way that
benefits them they've used that block to
protect their market share and to boost
their ad performance simultaneously
they've also worked with Adblock to
whitelist ads on most of their core
Services other than desktop YouTube the
bottom line is that Google understands
that eliminating Adblock is not the
solution the solution is to make ads
less intrusive less annoying and more
appealing the solution is to make the ad
experience so good that people don't
even feel the need to use Adblock even
if it's available and that's really
Google's ultimate goal or at least
that's the approach that Google has been
taking so far with the recession and the
stagnating ad rates Google May Backtrack
on this decision and decide to crack
down on an ad block to play shareholders
in the short term but personally I
believe that this would be a huge
mistake Google got it right the first
time working through Adblock is how
Google can truly overcome Adblock not by
just taking it down and that's why
Google still allows Adblock do you use
Adblock comment that down below also
drop a like if you hope that Google
sticks to this approach and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community such as the video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one